- This is rapid fire.
Ready? Here we go.
(slot machine ticks)
(ding)
"Question for Dwayne Johnson:
What is Black Adam's favorite
Dwayne Johnson movie?".
(laughing)
So?
- Oh, man. Um-
- [Kelly] Inquiring minds want to know.
- I would say Black Adam's favorite-
- [Pierce] Don't write this down.
- No, God, I'm like-
rolodex right now is going.
- Yeah, and you can't,
you can't say Black Adam.
You have to say something else, yeah.
- I made a movie one time
with my wife that I can't-
No, nevermind. Sorry.
(laughing)
(crowd clapping)
(indistinct, overlapping talking)
- The amount of time it
took for me to get that was-
I was like, I literally,
if they play back my face,
I went "that's sweet".
And then I go "Oh".
(laughing)
- Oh, my God.
- That would probably be a good-
Don't brag, okay, what's your favorite-
(laughing)
- That's all I got.
No, yeah, next question.
(laughing) I'm only
kidding. I'm only kidding.
- You have so many, just pick one.
- Okay.
- Jumanji, just pick it.
- Jumanji, yes, that's it.
- [Kelly] Jumanji.
- Jumanji.
(crowd clapping)
- Just pick it. I just threw one out.
I was like "you have so many great ones".